oh oh film level step over oh
me on the floor he's he's not was it the
film level double lollipop step over
is that what you've thrown in for
yeah yeah we're talking i've been
watching that for 20 years
hi it's gary neville and i'm doing rate
my skills for sport bible i'm going to
pick my favorite clip and the winner is
going to get a thousand pounds worth of
castor sportswear
oh this is a bit
this is a oh
oh he's good
why is he in sky blue though should be
in red that's the problem that's the
biggest problem with this kid he's
wearing their own colour
oh he's not scored that that is
unbelievable wow was that cross as well
do you think or do you think he's meant
to chip it into the back post
it doesn't really matter does it the bit
before it was fantastic as a kid were
you like that were you beating all the
players oh yeah yeah yeah just that was
me all over that
no that's not happening i've never done
that in my life
here we go what's going on here
how far is that wall away
no
oh my god
that's incredible
yeah oh oh film level step over oh
me on the floor he's he's not was it the
film level double lollipop step over
is that what you've thrown in for
yeah yeah we're talking i've been
watching that for 20 years
what can
he's good he's got good balance he's got
good technique
and he's got that ability where you know
just the worst thing for a fallback is
when
a player runs at you and it looks like
they could go both ways
yeah oh yes
that's my favorite that's the one
that is the one
absolutely let me just take it back has
he just done his mate
there he's gone through his mate there
you go he's done
she's run right through him
i did a few of them just something i was
never sort of someone when i was younger
that was a good tackler or anything but
you know with eric harrison
nobby styles sir alex ferguson roy
keynes brian robson these ferocious
characters coaches all around you that
you had to win the tackle if the
tackle's there you've got to try and win
it it's like your instinct is a defender
you know it just you cannot not win the
tackle
small pitch is it five a side
oh it's two goals i was looking at the
wrong goal
i was thinking he's shooting the one to
the left
hey some goal though well done to him
his teammates don't look too pleased
with him and he's actually in favor i
mean they're all walking away from him
about as popular as me
that's what that oh he's not giving it
to the ronaldo one
oh my god how's it that like that yeah i
like that one
oh he's gone from distance oh oh oh oh
dear
right
the keeper wasn't the most agile shall
we say he's too far off his line and
he's not expected it and it's an
unbelievable strike were you always
there and bets at the halfway then were
you yeah i was on the bench it was
unbelievable but i'd we'd all seen him
do it practicing it all the time in
training brilliant striker of a ball he
always tried these things
in the third place is the wonderful
cristiano style free kick
in second place
is the
the tackle it's
classic absolute brilliant tackle and in
first place and winning 1 000 pounds of
castor sportswear is the back heel top
corner free kick never seen anything
like that in my life
okay now we see back to oh okay
wow that's a goal and a half ball comes
back to the net whoops
flick it that's a a matte leticial
that's uh very good you can see that he
means that all the way wow and then for
the keeper it's impossible to think that
he's going to shoot from there
what a finish